[Music]
that's coming hey everybody its Charlie
a Hawkeye phase four project bet you
didn't see that coming so we got some
more details about what's going on with
Hawkeye during phase four we had some
early rumors a while ago but now some of
those things have been confirmed about
when is actually going to happen what
story they're gonna do and where you'll
be able to watch it they'll be new
giveaway stuff happening at the end of
the video be sure to subscribe if you're
brand new to the channel so first things
first Kevin Feige a while ago confirmed
that in Avengers 4 in phase 4 we'd be
seeing new versions of existing Avengers
characters so a lot of people at the
time just assumed that they were talking
about future versions of Captain America
because of all the talk that Chris Evans
has been doing about how he might not do
any Marvel movies after Avengers 4
doesn't mean that he'll never come back
just means he's the leading candidate to
pass his mantle on we've been talking
about Bucky maybe replacing him as
Captain America for a couple years now
or even Anthony Mackey's Falcon
character like they did in the comics
there are so many people that have
wielded the mantle of Captain America in
the comics that is just a foregone
conclusion that they'll do that at some
point instead of recasting Steve Rogers
so you can have both of those characters
it's just the one calls themselves by
either Captain America or say hawkeye's
name which is where we get to the
Hawkeye solo project so a little while
ago after they confirmed that they were
making the Black Widow movie we heard
rumors about a Hawkeye movie with Jeremy
Renner and Kate Bishop that would be him
passing the mantle like he did in the
comics so recently what happened is is
some of those reports were confirmed
with a couple big changes so now what's
happening is is the Hawkeye project is
still very much a thing behind the
scenes at marble they're still working
on it but it sounds more like they're
leaning towards an 8 to 10 episode
premium series for that Disney streaming
service because remember how they just
announced Tom Hiddleston was doing a
low-key TV series and Scarlet Witch was
doing a TV series for that Disney
streaming service so it's basically how
Disney gets you to pay for that like how
many people have been asking for a
Hawkeye Netflix series since they
started doing Marvel
applix TV shows like this would be
perfect you could do really hardcore
they want people to buy into it that's
why they're doing this hardcore
Mandalorian Star Wars TV series they're
doing these Marvel premium series with
a-list Avengers characters so Scarlet
Witch and Loki are just the first of
many big TV series with Avengers
characters that is Kevin Feige puts it
have not gotten solo movies so that's
why they're the characters that are
getting TV series like they're probably
not gonna do an it Fury solo movie
there's been talk that they're gonna do
an it Fury TV series on this Disney
streaming service that's still just a
rumor right now and honestly I would
rather see a Hawkeye TV series before a
Nick Fury TV series even though Sam
Jackson going crazy on every one for
eight episodes does sound pretty nuts
right now there's no director there's no
writer attached to it they haven't
announced anything other than what the
story would be based on and as you would
expect it's based on the fraction run
totally it would feel a lot like that
with Jeremy Renner's version of Hawkeye
because the personality of his Hawkeye
is a little bit different from comic
book Hawkeye but you get the idea all
you need to hear is is that they're
doing the fraction run and that tells
you pretty much everything you need to
know about what its gonna feel like I
know you all want to know when the hell
is gonna drop when can I watch episodes
big series like this typically take a
few years to develop between casting
filming writing special effects so
timeline if we're not getting episodes
of that Loki or Scarlet Witch TV series
until 2020 at the earliest you can bet
that any kind of Hawkeye project
probably wouldn't drop until 2021 which
is like early mid phase for because it's
him training a successor who we haven't
seen anywhere in the MCU yet that means
he would probably have to survive
Avengers 4 there are still a few
question mark phase 1 Avengers about
whether they'll live or die but after
all this Chris Evans business Huck I
dropped off my death predictions list
really you only need to sacrifice one of
your biggest characters to get that
gut-wrenching payoff you don't need to
get rid of all them this isn't like Star
Wars rogue one you all probably heard
this past weekend the Kathryn Langford
from 13 reasons why joined the cast of
Avengers 4 as a secret character she's
already filmed her scenes we have no
idea who she's playing she's a pretty
high profile young actress right now so
it's possible she's playing an older
of an existing child actor in the MCU
they've already cast a teenage version
of Cassie Lang it's this actress so
obviously it's not her so unless
Catherine Lankford is playing an even
older version of Cassie that's in her
20s she could be playing somebody in a
flashback or just a different big
character that shows up in the future
all of the Kate Bishop fan art you've
been seeing the last couple of days is
just that it's fan art none of this has
been confirmed people are like who's she
playing there's just a couple of female
characters that were expecting them to
introduce in the future and as she's
really really young there are only a
couple of people that she could be if
she is playing a big comic book
character but the big thing about Kate
Bishop is is that she was introduced in
a young avengers arc when they had to
battle to defeat khang the conquer Kevin
Feige confirmed that they're thinking
about doing a younger vengers movie
there'll be a couple of Easter eggs for
that during Avengers 4 primarily the
Cassie Lange character because like I
said Kate Bishop showed up for the first
time during a Young Avengers arc the
older version of Cassie Lang who had
become stature was a big character
during that so what a coincidence that
all this young avengers stuff is
happening but the Young Avengers arc is
very different from the fraction or
Young Avengers introduces her she sort
of combines a couple different
characters costumes to form her Hawkeye
costume Clint Barton recognises what a
badass she is takes her under his wing
and then during the fraction arc it's
the process of him just sort of laying
it all on her like this is what it means
to do what I do so it's a bit of a
generational buddy-cop flick but you
have to keep in mind the differences in
MCU Hawkeye when comic book Hawkeye was
training Cape Bishop he didn't have the
family that MCU Hawkeye does he just had
an apartment building so it was
literally him on his own with this girl
showing up in his life who he was trying
to teach to become a superhero MCU
Hawkeye has been trying to retire back
to his farm permanently for so long you
could turn it into a meme
this is an agent of some kind gentlemen
this is Laura ain't no names
coming dessert moderations he kind of
retired after Avengers age of Ultron
then came out for the events of civil
war then as we found out during Avengers
infinity war an ant-man and the wasp
he's been under permanent house arrest
since relatively soon after Captain
America busted them all out of the raft
so he did a little bit of Secret
Avengers stuff before he cut that deal
with the government but two big things
let me know in the comments who do you
think the Kathryn Langford is playing
and if she's not gonna be Kate Bishop
who do you want that to be in the MCU
there's a whole bunch more Marvel stuff
coming up there is a new round of that
spider-man ps4 game giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a mark or related comments on
the video if you want me to change the
giveaway to be for something else just
let me know in the comments - but click
here to learn why Hulk I becomes Ronan
during Avengers 4 and click here for
that brand new Aquaman trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you